welcome to Norway Norway the western
part of Scandinavia was established in
the year 872 the beautiful country home
to [ __ ] an influential black metal
scene a large nationalized oil company
in these arctic foxes so cute
so while Norway has a long and storied
history let's focus on 2009 no cultural
event we compared to the gargantuan
colossal mammoth very large in size
phenomenon of this train traveling from
Oslo to Bergen televised for seven hours
straight
this is slow TV
slow TV is LCD is a way of telling
stories that is told in full-length
along an unbroken timeline this guy
works as a norwegian broadcasting
company and my name is Thomas Elam I'm
working as a project manager currently
working a lot with real slow
shroom shroom TV he helps create a type
of television series that shows the
subjective is somehow rooted in the
region culture or that many people can
can relate to so some examples are
marathon long episodes of people Salomon
fishing 18 hours it took three hours
before we go to first fish 60 hours the
choir performing 899 hymns from the book
of Norway we have the notion of firewood
night with a fireplace burning for eight
hours you get the idea but how did
Thomas come upon the idea and this is
actually done by accident well so in
2009 Thomas is at lunch with some
colleagues they're following some ideas
their discussions over topics that take
long time and other stories that you
could sort of tell us they evolve after
a lot of talk one of us just said why
don't we film the whole train journey
from the western part in Norway to
eastern part of Norway it takes 7 hours
and and we why don't we just film the
whole thing and put it up on TV they
look at about this and first they lost
and didn't quite understand what we
suggested that after have laughed a
little bit they realize that maybe this
was a good idea so they got to work and
planned it out
November 27 2009 the experiment was
released on air to Thomas's surprise 1.6
million in Wheaton was part of the
program how much people and after that
we we saute this is the way we can tell
other stories as well the next
production was going to be even bigger a
five and a half day boat trip going
along and our Weejun Coast televised in
real time and we transmitted the world's
longest TV documentary angle can then
use no commercials no nothing except
this journey for five and a half days
and 3.2 million Norwegian follow that
journey well than half of the population
of Norway tuned in at some point of the
broadcast but why what made this show so
popular part of it of course it's that
it was something completely different
the sealy was no longer a TV screen but
sort of a window as they were actually
doing the journey as their own best
ships they own that train after eight
years
Thomas and Syria are still pushing the
envelope if somebody has told you that
eight years ago that hey you are going
to make it twelve hour
p41 I would have said they were
completely crazy
[Music]
yeah
[Music]